denise the number of deadly crashes in
nevada has already surpassed last year's
number there are more than 300 the spike
due mainly to more and more pedestrians
being hit and killed by cars
madison kimbrough got some answers as to
what is being done to combat the issue
and also what intersections we need to
look out for madison joins us live with
the latest
we're currently at one of the busiest
intersections in the valley take a look
as we're here at sahara and el camino
where the most recent person was hit and
killed by a car wednesday morning
[Music]
statewide we have seen an increase in
pedestrians being hit and killed along
with motorcyclists bicyclists and
scooters as well busy intersections like
sahara and decatur and all along boulder
highway especially at twain are just
some of the main areas we see this
happening according to the nevada office
of traffic safety there has been more
than a 50 percent increase in
motorcyclist hit and killed this year 10
people on bicycles scooters or mopeds
have died compared to one at this time
last year aaron breen with the road
equity alliance says it's time we start
looking at las vegas as a commuter town
and really focus on the people around us
if we're going to seriously talk about
reducing the number of pedestrians
killed we need to change the speed that
people are traveling it's not just the
core of las vegas anymore now we're
seeing that those dangerous streets
spread further and further to the north
and the south and the east and the west
breen also says we need more traffic
lights more cameras and to increase the
number of speed limit signs out on the
roads
failure to yield to pedestrians in the
number one reason for these fatalities
followed by speed impairment and
distractions reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now